OF TOUCH ON SOMETHING THAT I
NEVER KNEW.
I WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO EXPAND
ON IT.
YOU SAID THAT IN 2007, THERE
WAS A MOMENT WHEN YOU WERE
ALMOST TRADING FOR KOBE.
PLEASE TELL ME THAT STORY.
>> I WAS IN DANCING WITH THE
STARS.
WE PRACTICE A LOT.
LIKE SEVEN OR EIGHT HOURS A DAY
BECAUSE I NEEDED IT.
I WAS GOING BACK AND FORTH WITH
DR. BUSS AND I FORGET WHO
CALLED WHO.
I THINK HE CALLED ME AND SAID I
THINK WE MIGHT BE PARTING WAYS
WITH KOBE.
I REMEMBER IT BECAUSE THERE WAS
A P.A.
WHO WAS JUST LIKE LAKERS,
LAKERS, LAKERS, LAKERS.
WE HAD JUST GONE TO THE FINALS
THE YEAR BEFORE.
WE WOULD TALK ABOUT KOBE.
IT WAS KOBE, KOBE, COPLEY ALL
THE TIME.
SO IT STARTED TO HAPPEN.
I STARTED TELLING HIM ABOUT IT.
THAT WAS THE KISS OF DEATH
BECAUSE THE MINUTE I TOLD HIM,
IT ALL FELL APART.
>> WHY DID IT FALL APART?
>> BECAUSE MITCH KUPCHAK TALKED
KOBE INTO STAYING.
IT WAS LIKE WITH DeANDRE.
WHEN A GUY THAT IS KEY TO YOUR
TEAM WANTS TO LEAD, YOU'RE
GOING TO DO EVERYTHING YOU CAN
TO KEEP HIM.
>> WHAT WOULD THIS KOBE MAVS
TEAM  HAVE LOOKED LIKE?
>> IT WOULD'VE BEEN GOOD.
>> DIRK WAS LIKE, I WOULD'VE
TRADED ME FOR KOBE.
>> I SAID WE ARE NOT GOING TO
TRADE YOU, DIRK.
>> IT'S CRAZY TO THINK ABOUT
ALL THE THINGS THAT WOULD'VE
CHANGED WITH THAT TRAIT.
>> YOU NEVER KNOW.
>> THEN THEY TRADED FOR PAUL
CASALE AND EVERY THINGS
DIFFERENT.
IN THE NBA, YOU ARE ONE
SPRAINED ANKLE OR TRADE AWAY
AND EVERYTHING CAN CHANGE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS DONE.
>> IT WAS DONE.
LIKE